[Music]
my journey was definitely one about
being alone it wasn't so much sharing a
dynamic with a team it was all I was
always alone I was always doing
something by myself traveling by myself
playing by myself working on solutions
to problems by myself everything was
done alone that was Ryan Hart if you
haven't heard of him before he's one of
the greatest fighting game players to
ever come out of Europe but his path to
the top wasn't easy it was paved with
loneliness and a diversity because as a
teenager
Brian Hart was homeless hungry and alone
on the streets of London such a massive
thing to experience because when you go
through that over an extended period it
starts to eat away at some of your most
core in a beating you know and it's it
starts to become a challenge to just I
don't know it sounds weird but like just
to stay the same starved for both food
and human connection Reinhardt found
that fighting games weren't just games
they were his deliverance from a
desperate time like the security that I
had created in my head was completely
torn apart and I kind of didn't really
know what happens like it's not
something you've ever learned about like
what happens not and I didn't know
anyone that had a similar experience I
had no reference points whatsoever but
the drift of my life just kind of led me
to lean on games a little bit more
because you know it was it's it's where
life was easy to be honest it was where
I can just be okay for a bit you know I
don't know like this was my way to chill
out this was my way to socialize on my
way to relax forget everything else and
just kind of be free
[Music]
before he was a four-time fighting game
Guinness world record holder Reinhart
was a ten-year-old kid living in Croydon
a borough in London and he really loved
playing Street Fighter 1 with his
friends at the arcade arcades were
everywhere fact that and provided a
social space for kids like heart to do
something together feel like they were
part of something bigger and just make
friends
Kamiya I think it just was stumbling
upon a minicab station and what's this
going in there putting some of my pocket
money in playing a game for the first
time and enjoying it and that's how it
began
but when Street Fighter 2 came along
things started to get a little bit more
intense the game was obviously more
complex but it was also more competitive
all of a sudden everyone wanted to be
the best and while Hart wasn't good he
still considered himself to be average
in those early days of arcade gaming's
people didn't really travel to other
arcades they just stayed in their own
areas and plating as their friends that
is until the tournament was announced in
central London and that really lit a
fire under everyone's ass I remember one
guy came to the arcade and said that in
central London which was like our hub
for everything there will be a
tournament and it would be the first one
of its kind there's never been one
before and I was like this is 1994 so to
my knowledge at least this is the first
ever fighting game tournament in Europe
I never heard about anything before that
and people came down in the hundreds
from different communities it was
absolutely insane
up until that point many people
including Hart just saw fighting games
as a past something fun to do with your
friends but winning a 1996 Kos 96
tournament was a real turning point for
Hart before beating other players was
good enough after that win though he
tasted blood in the water
but just as Reinhart was gaining
momentum in a burgeoning fgc tragedy
struck there was a situation where the
landlord hadn't been paying the mortgage
that was like private renting to tenants
and my family was a were tenants and so
when he kind of got flagged and was
forced to like vacate the premises we
were then made to as well and that's
where it begins basically that's kind of
how it all happened and then that kind
of eventually ended up with nowhere to
live all of a sudden a teenaged heart
found himself without a roof over his
head facing an uncertain future and
literally not knowing where his next
meal would come from I mean because they
were literally times of depression to
the point where like I've got no money
I'm super hungry and I was fined like 10
P 10 pence on the floor and that would I
grab that and I'd be like okay I've
added that to what I've got and you know
soon I can buy a burger emotionally Hart
struggled to feel like anyone gave a
damn and left to fend for himself he
felt he was the guest character and
other people's lives it's hard to still
stay really strong in who you are as a
person when you're constantly left alone
in solitude like on a daily basis but
it's not because you're locked up in a
room or something you're out and about
you're on the streets you're in the city
you're seeing people living their lives
day to day with families friends
partners whatever you're seeing
everything happen all around you but
inside of being around those millions
you're completely alone like I had a guy
who said I could stay a place and then
like I say I think I didn't have many
clothes I didn't have more a lot of
money so I didn't have many clothes and
I think I stayed where I ran off its
clothes I borrow some of his you know he
had like closing he had like a kind of
used this place is kind of like a I know
like a warehouse or something
so I a couple of the items there to wear
because I don't have any clothes
one day I came back and he had like sold
all my PlayStation games my playstation
my joystick to the bag that the stuff
came in and let's walking like 50 60
PlayStation games and that's why a lot
of money is his way back in the 90s when
like he's retailed at good money you
know this was like really premium stuff
for me and for me being in my situation
where I didn't have a place to live I
didn't have a job this was my only money
you know money this was my only source
of income times like this now where this
guy had just basically sold all my stuff
without asking me just because I brought
a couple of items of clothing you know
those things hurt a lot and it's
basically a time where no one respects
you as well because of your situation
they kind of look down on you but I
borrowed a lot of money in that time
from friends from people that trusted me
obviously I had friends who helped me
out with food you know my friend was a
chef in a restaurant and he used to like
sneak me up into his restaurant without
his dad knowing because if that owned
the restaurant easiest me it was
ridiculous like it was in China Tania
sneaked back to the restaurant like
insane o'clock right like 5:00 a.m. or
some nonsense when they're still setting
up to open the restaurant later when
they cook all the food in the morning
and he would make me breakfast before he
would start the shift he would cook a
breakfast for me happy breakfast on the
side while he's actually working and
this is with like all his other
colleagues in the kitchen so it was
really really kind of him he just kind
of had me there and I'd have something
to eat and then it you know I got gum
about my business to avoid getting
dragged down by the sheer negativity of
the whole situation Hart tried to spend
as much time around other people as
possible but he also had to do a little
bit of self care as well that's where
fighting games came in they were another
way that he kept his spirits up so often
times I was very much just kind of in my
own corner like you know this is only
for now it's gonna be fine we'll go out
there you know and kind of just working
through things and like by myself like
that so being in central London was
because it was a very active area so
even late at night even two-three for
him there's people everywhere you know
coming home from clubbing or coming up
doing lay shifts at work or whatever
just being there at that time it was a
very thriving and vibrant area so it was
nice to be there when I knew I didn't
have anywhere to be s times of the
morning right so yeah very difficult
insecure yourself already you don't know
on the outside of that and then you kind
of always end up falling back home well
at least in my case I did kind of fall
back on this game anything even though
Hart was playing and fighting game
tournaments at the time he wasn't using
them to earn a consistent income that's
because the prizes were usually video
games which he collected and could sell
one day because what would happen is I'd
win tournaments and then I would take
the games to a secondhand stop to be
sold and then I'd use that money in and
I'd be okay for a while and sometimes
that would carry me to the next
tournament and then I'd win again and or
do okay you know I'll get whatever from
that and then that would last me so it
was a very difficult you know period
where you're not secure you're very like
literally there were times where I
didn't know where my next meal will come
from kind of thing like like literally
like that you know now you might be
thinking he was winning tournaments so
he should have landed a sponsor or
something right well the thing is
eSports teams and sponsorships were
pretty unheard of in the early 2000
especially for fighting games hearts
first sponsorship came from a Namco
arcade whose owners want him to play
against other people because he could
beat them faster than the CPU could I
think initially I was offered a bus one
day traveled a monthly travel card ah a
sandwich and free credits at the arcade
and that was your probably very first
ever tiniest per diem package ever you
know it lasted you that the arcade Namco
this sponsorship from a Japanese company
mark the beginning of hearts a lifelong
love affair with the premiere
destination for fighting games Japan
it was Ryan Hart's dream to travel to
Japan because that's where most of the
games he loved were made and when he
turned 18 that dream came true but yeah
I had this burst of happiness in Japan
where they really helped me out and you
know the fighting game community is a
special place because someone like me
who had nothing in life could find a
home in the violin community heart went
to Japan after winning the ERG eyes UK
championship in 1998 his prize was a
ticket to compete in the World Finals in
the Land of the Rising Sun but sadly
one's heart beats Japan he was defeated
by the time I actually got to go to
Japan fortunately a few people already
knew me there because I a lot of you
know a Japanese exchange students that
visited London have come to the arcades
played against me and talked about me
when they went back to Japan so I
actually went you're already like 5 to
10 media guys waiting for me outside
this time I killed man speaking Japanese
I got they wanted to be me and it was it
was so nice like I felt so appreciated I
mean you have to remember they don't
know but back home I'm completely
homeless after the loss a friend
suggested that Hart extend his Tokyo
stay and he agreed it was this adventure
just walking around Tokyo looking for
arcades and just learning more because
obviously while you're looking for
arcades you find like oh this is a cool
book shop here oh that's a nice
restaurant here oh maybe I can do this
next time you know so like there's all
these you just it was just this crazy
land of fantasy for a long time and I
think that's probably why at least now
especially being a dying breed the
arcade life in Japan will always be very
very special in my eyes during his
two-month adventure in Japan Hart
entered the King of Fighters 98 world
tournament and he won that tournament it
was a it was up on a post day in that
plane that's arcade and that's how I
found out about it was just on a post at
25th of September come down to this
tournament we know and yeah and so I win
and it was yeah if I watch a [ __ ] but
it wasn't all fame and glory far from it
Hart was an unfamiliar territory and the
Japanese arcade gamers were wiping the
floor with him
they were being me in such a way Wow
couldn't even put any pieces together I
don't know why they knew this and that
and they were able to just play they
stopped playing with your mind and you
know really start infiltrating your
brain it's horrible it's a horrible
feeling when someone's in your head his
very first a loss on Japanese soil came
at the hands of an elderly shopkeeper
sound like a what looked like a
newspaper shop that we'd have an K like
a sweet shot and I went in there and
there was one arcade cabinet in this
small shop just one arcade cabinet back
to back Sun screens so I sat down put my
coin in you know a hundred unicredit
that stop tangles brush fighter three at
that time TV so he picked three
characters and they're playing this game
against computer and the game all of a
sudden said here comes a new challenge I
don't like what I'm looking around for
the shots completely end there's not a
single customer in the shop I look up
and the old man the shop owner is
challenging something yeah this guy
kicked my ass so badly I could not let
this old dude gray hair like I'm like
what's going on and that was just the
first of many losses Hart experienced in
Japan over time losing over and over
again to amateur Japanese players got
too hard to handle but getting battered
every day for hours you know like it's
too much after so much time especially
if you're someone who's supposedly you
know where you're from you got stature
you know you're someone but yeah when I
went there it was just hardcore yet
again heartfelt isolated he couldn't
speak the language and everyone he knew
was on the other side of the world
hearten knew he was at a disadvantage
against the Japanese players who had a
ton of information at their disposal
thanks to both strategy guides called
mooks
the fact that they could just talk to
each other about the game it was really
hard because they had so much more at
their disposal than I did they had were
called nooks magazine books where it's
basically a magazine which teaches you
how to play the game and these can
contain everything from Matt's verse you
know character match tips to frame data
to combo DVDs to exhibition matches like
literally everything you could ever need
to master if I could be contained in one
book ultimately after running the
Japanese arcade gauntlet day after day
hard we get to see his newfound
vulnerability as a learning opportunity
because to get better you need to learn
by losing write to improve to actually
be good you need to lose a lot first he
use the infamous Shinjuku Sports land
arcade as a kind of dojo facing opponent
after opponent but like his own personal
kryptonite that feeling of being left
out continue to play guard you also had
that they were congregating and talking
about things and sharing things together
and having matches to test certain
strategies and all of this even though
they were all happening in front of me
because I can understand the dialogue I
wasn't connected to any other so and
that also adds to the feeling of
loneliness and the man by myself here
you know doesn't help you to feel good
about the scenario but there was
definitely a light at the end of the
tunnel see as the day went on the
opponents at the arcade got stronger and
stronger but gradually Hart noticed that
he was staying on the sticks longer and
he was knocking a rival after rival off
the machine the strongest players came
down later in the day the earlier in the
day was the more wind she could get that
was the answer
unwritten rule if you go there 12 p.m.
you probably get 10 wins in a row
understand players are not that good
later it gets the higher the level gets
okay so by 10 p.m. if you're still
playing you're one of the best you won't
be playing cuz you looked in you looked
in being by that time because they're
just too good my test would be how late
can I stay on till yeah you know and
yeah there were times where I could play
to a 4 p.m. and then I'd get kicked off
there some won't be me at 4 and a 4 and
then the next like I think like a week
later I could there was a I lost it I
was at 6 p.m. Oh
the yeah after about a month about a
month on a week of staying in Japan just
playing games every day I think there
was this time where I got like 26 wins
in a row the first time it ever happened
where I got 20 so the first time that I
remember seeing a 2 in front when I got
when I hit 20 on that oh my god 20 wins
in a row and I got a 26 streak and then
I lost and I was really upset I could
have had that I did a low kick and I was
going over why is pop on and I looked at
that time and it was 10 over 10 it was
10 10 just all the top heads and so yeah
after about a month in a week only the
best players could you know take me off
and finally after 2 months it was time
for the prodigal son to return home
in the end outside of whatever time he
spent traveling Hart had nowhere to live
for just over two years relying on the
kindness of friends and his mother just
to get by after that a couple of years a
friend had said I can stay his face for
some time I stayed there and then like
eventually got a property back I think I
moved back home with my mom at some
point and actually got a place and then
moved back in with my mom and I had my
own room again and everything so but you
know it was different I was matured I
have been I'd seen some stuff I'd
experienced things I had you know a lot
has changed a lot of irreversible things
have changed you know so it was it was
different
yeah it really was the experience also
made Hart a more resilient player who
could use gaming to bear fit in with the
world around him my drive back then was
very being a very fierce competitor but
also just having a natural love and
passion for the community and for the
games themselves because of how deep
they were and how much you could express
yourself through these games it was it
was just a about creative expression for
me my 2009
part had proved himself and he joined
his first real eSports team a lowland
Alliance as the head of their fighting
game division but even after making the
big leagues he still felt his old
adversary creeping up on him this team
factor didn't I didn't I don't know I
didn't get in better than that naturally
it was very like I was very distant from
that it really originally you know even
though I was on the team also playing
for myself you know in time heart warmed
up to the team dynamic he knew that
there were people that depended on it so
that changed after some months I think I
matured in the area I think I started to
learn the bigger picture so to speak I
start to learn more about what the value
of player branding the value of you know
being a team member what that means how
you need to represent present yourself
wearing a team jersey like just all
these different extra elements that come
in when you actually part of a team
right Reinhardt has won many hats over
the years on top of being a pro gamer
part has also worked as a commentator
tournament organizer event host
presenter translator model and contact
creme
after all as impressive as holding four
Guinness World Records is including one
for the most international street
fighter tournament wins
and that pays the bills these days Hart
hopes to support the up-and-coming
generation of gamers by being the mentor
that he himself never had I didn't have
anyone I could then turn to a NAS for
support you know and that's horrible
it's a people say yeah but you learn
from that but it was a harmful
experience to learn in that way I'd much
rather have had someone who could go
through it with me and say hey this is
what you need to work on and then I work
on that by myself and then that still
good because I still learn but I don't
spend a lot of time in agony English
wondering and worrying if I'm doing the
right thing
so what's next for Reinhardt well his
aspirations are pretty humble I'd like
my movements my work would have to help
people to push themselves in whatever
they're doing and I hope that could come
from people that they asked me or do
anything any endeavor when every day's
today Hart has won over a hundred
fighting game tournaments in five
continents across 25 countries including
two Eva World Championships but what
lies beyond this victory just like a
real life for you the wandering warrior
Reinhardt will continue to master his
fighting game skills after all he can't
beat a real fighter
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]